je voulais faire quand vous étiez petit
vous c'était quoi vous pourrez vous
voulez faire toi comme métier beynat une
boulette eux j'ai quasiment tout de
suite voulu être journaliste mais juste
auparavant quand je cherchais le métier
je voulais voyager beaucoup voir du
monde et donc j'aime et eddy hôtesse de
l'air sans vida hymne hôtesse de l'air
olala j'aurais on aurait dit hôtesse de
l'air bnm on aurait voulu la paix chaud
dans laquelle elle te dis sucré salé
je connais tu connais que tu connais
quand avec une meuf
tu connais quand avec une meuf dans
l'avion etc à des turbulences et tu fais
j'en suis tout de suite en août mais en
fait tu es en mini raz sera quand même
tu veux des cacahuètes à m attention je
veux dire après si on doit s'écraser au
dossier s'écrasera été battus c'est
hélas tu sors toujours ses fans
tu sais tu as beaucoup plus de chances
de faire un accident de la route
d'autres mais ça y est tu veux faire le
mec jean legault ce beau mais masse
cosmique dans un avion frère tu peux
rien faire abarth et moi voilà même mois
voilà on a même fait peur en avion ou
moyens non mais elle est perdue par
doudou sortir on appris avec vous
l'avions pas peut-être du fait que tu me
serrait la main comme un signe
[Rires]
également la bonne jeux partout dans un
mois et la peur il aime pas mais de ne
pas maîtriser tous voulaient mettre ddd
dénonce dans la tête j'ai tout oublié
bien faire et c'est surtout que j'ai pas
compris beaucoup de mettre une petite
ceinture tout ridicule on a là c'est
parce qu'en fait la ceinture de chakwal
sert à quoi c'est juste pour toi que tu
donnes la tête devant ces bons mourir
d'accord me connaît la tête non mais
c'est quand il ya des idées de la
décoration
je sais en tout cas moi j'ai un copain
journée ton avion et ben le petit la
yann là mais il a sauté comme ça ça peut
être la folie comme ça la connaît comme
ça vous touche plus posé que je le crois
quand on fait un pari nancy on vous
montre comment mettre à un gilet de
sauvetage
enfin paris nancy alors je vais vous
dire pourquoi on sait jamais parce que
vous pouvez passer par la scène et
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on avait un sac en amérique selon la
mairie alors nous qui allons prendre
l'avion bientôt bêtise avait des gens un
peu vous dire on commencera pas angoissé
où l'ennui il était en ballottage avant
qu'il ait pris maintenant ah oui noyer
prix c'est sûr que si je peux venir
accompagnés ou pas oui oui oui oui
tout ce que vous voudrez tout ce que
vous voudrez du moment que vous êtes là
et il vient avec yves with high key 20
04 quand même y'a quelqu'un de
l'extérieur vous verrez vous d'aller
choisir où vous ferez on fera une
émission spéciale pour choisir de
jean-michel baer ce que je voulais ce
que j'aurais pu faire plus tôt imitateur
un ordinateur meet a tall et les
rabbanim a fait le masi a voulu que je
fasse une chanson non mais non mais vous
liez dmitri tateurs que vous étiez petit
oui j'aurais pu gérer la carrière
s'ouvrait j'ai préféré prendre un autre
chemin mais je la lui qui a des
problèmes d'entente orthophoniste
[Rires]
je vous fais termine ferme les yeux
parmi eux attendent le plus aimé mettre
de se trouver
tu veux là nous pas si mal excuse moi
mais rien en quelques instants
c'est un bordel
latendresse
allez faites après génération mais 72 et
salue sa génération
et puis l'aurait voulu faire mini clubs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
partout moi je voulais de zorro ah ouais
bah oui plutôt non
[Rires]
ouais c'est pas ça c'était donc j'avais
5 ans avec machado berson de ma
génération voulait être zorro ou thierry
la fronde a ouais ouais j'ai posé la
question à renault chanteur il a eu une
panoplie de zorro aussi dans sa
génération away sympa ça les zorro est
arrivé en france en 64 à la télévision
et on l'a pas reconnu au départ non mais
c'est vrai et la chanson d'henri
salvador tout bien sûr nantaise de
churros
ces machines qui me fascinait c'était il
y avait eu en fait y avait la peur à
nivelles comme ça on tournait ils ont
coupé les fils et huawei ah ouais c'est
sûr mais je voulais couper mais bon on
vous l'a jamais achetées pour votre
anniversaire banon est bas ce sera fait
ouais franchement machines ont fait ça
ouais ouais ouais vous l'aurez chez vous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
notre adversaire c'est grand s'est fait
abattre à mes vacances d'enfance c'est
eh ben voilà bah voilà bond à votre
cadeau sescoi notice oui alors vous
alors si vous n'avez pas tes artistes à
succès j'aurais arrêté n'est parce que
j'ai très vite compris
mais nenê oui parce que j'ai très vite
compris que l'oenologue ne veut pas non
mais pas pour n'ai pas faim je m'en fous
parce que pour l'amour quand tu sens
l'autre c'est physique qui est un truc
qui se passe et tu sais si ça va aller
par exemple ma me sens pas bon mais
[Applaudissements]
quand tu vas faire l'amour ou quoi
l'odeur l'odeur ça marche avant que je
peux pas vous par exemple tout de suite
la ruine oberle assez physique là là là
encore je m'approche la super mamie nous
sans toi mamie notion très bon témoin tu
sais ce que tu sens
enfin côté là
[Applaudissements]
oh la la
non alors vous vous sentez de pain
d'épicés prématuré batteur youplaboum
[Applaudissements]
des personnes blessées décollage ne
seront pas populaires des villes et
districts tu couches avec way parfois
l'hôte de il ya un truc mais je sais
aussi que c'est moi qui avais de
personnes sortaient le grade aulas mais
c'est vrai bel effort
oui car si vous l'êtes vous lis est
opticien non non non je voulais figurez
vous êtes gigolo gigolo bas vous avez
réussi au pas de course a été hyper
boulemia cas
avec un carnet débrouille à 15 ans il a
beaucoup tu as eu pour tout à fait nous
tiens les yeux qui été rétrécie alors un
non moi je fais pas ça tous les
benjamins
parce que son père m'a dit maman tu
devais t'appeler césario c'est vrai tu
suivais ta grand-mère et 12 ea césario
n'ont en fait pas césar parce que ma
mère a accouché par césarienne
ben oui oui ma grand mère dijana la
clinique de bullway candle nous fait
rire oui jeune lisa forceps je l'avais
pas vu salabert aloyse à bradl ger vous
voulez faire quoi vous quand vous étiez
là encore j'ai tout de suite apprécié et
aimé quand j'étais petite je rêvais
notre concierge à webb avait pas mais
j'adore c'est ce que font tous les gens
resteraient bas s'évase secret on
participe à leur vie je saurai avec qui
je me serais mêlée moi moi j'ai adoré la
rentrée avec qui vous rend très bas
baisser monde a compris que mes cheveux
soyeux la guerre ça tu vas tu es un jour
la lumière du jour cela va mieux alors
vous moi je voulais laisser une trace en
étant architectes
[Rires]
il est des rôles où un scénario c'est
bon scénario calme au dehors un
gratte-ciel faire des tours des
gratte-ciel maison des ponts à sympa
mais après ça reste un café la pyramide
par exemple je sais et même celui qui
affecte au blaireau gains déjà séjourné
en paix franchement oui oui vous allez
voir moi c'est très bizarre je voulais
faire et boire on voit quand j'étais
petite j'adorais malheur et que j'adore
et j'adorais les mecs sans démagogie
bonjour je regarde je regarde souvent
elle et a des répercussions sur le
camion moi j'adorais les mecs qui jette
le ca qui s'accroche derrière et sauter
et maintenant on fait quoi et un point
que j'étais parti en vacances hollande
avec le score mais jugent injuste
demander ce que voulait faire je m'en
fous maintenant ce que je vais faire au
nom non alors il donc vous êtes parti on
va concerner je fais partie en hollande
et j'étais parti en tournée le matin
avec les éboueurs de 9h matin de 9
heures du matin jusqu'à 20 heures
la famille hollandaise savais pas où
j'étais avait appelé la police dimon
rapatrier directement qui lie c'est fini
la semaine de vacances c'est terminé tu
rentres à gare du nord
mon père il vient le chercher gare du
nord comme quoi c'était la journée de la
lose il y avait une plaque en ferraille
il venait d'acheter une renault 21 à
crédit
mais la voiture dans la plaque en
ferraille il rentrer la voiture dans la
plaquant ferrals renforcée
au tout début je voulais être
journaliste n'est par jour est apparu un
type qui s'appelait dominique rocheteau
karaoui dominant auch tôt c'était la
synthèse de la roque sera et du football
à domicile vers vous dominique rocheteau
gré 76 c'est surtout c'est qui a
terrassé 4 heures d'essayage placer
votre idole quand vous étiez petit il et
j'ai même ramené une photo de vous et de
votre idole dominique rocheteau comme
une photo d'un microshow demandé à la
régie long il sait même pas qu'il va me
falloir de l'ange vert ah ouais j'suis
print au fake car oui on était ensemble
ah oui en 2004 signé le 2 mai alors vous
dise
on n'a pas ça y est mais l'ange vert
longeverne homme est ce pas mais en tout
cas donc c'était et c'est oublier de
quoi je voulais te veut devenir
footballeur
ah ouais assura vous êtes passé quand
même non j'ai fait une carrière de
footballeur au bâtiment type ah bah
voilà bah ouais 6 mai à temps il est
très sportif en lui et sportif est gelée
vu faire le chemin là et c'est une fois
à séoul et vous seriez vous moi je
voulais aider les autres non non non moi
je m'envoie j'ai toujours voulu être à
quelle heure je veux dire non pas du
tout je voulais de chanteurs et danseurs
[Applaudissements]
je voulais être chanteur non mais je
chanterai prochainement à l'est rien
juste qu'il aurait pu tout faire
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
allez tout temps une grenade tuant ses
notes accueil qui aura rien voilà tout